- Good morning, Believe Nation.
It's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey.
Today's message is paint what you want.
Over to you, Warren Buffet.
(rooster crowing)
(hip-hop music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- What brings you the most satisfaction?
Beyond family.
- Well, (laughs) my most
greatest satisfaction
is just staying in good health.
I mean, when you're 86, I mean,
you look at this a little differently.
(laughter)
But I...
- So you're in good health?
- Oh yeah.
I mean, I enjoy every day, I enjoy...
- [Interviewer] But what
is it that you enjoy?
- Well, I enjoy running Berkshire.
I mean, if you get right down
into my psyche, I mean...
- [Interviewer] That's
what I want to hear.
- Yeah, no, it's, you know,
it's been my painting for 50-some years.
I get to paint what I want.
I don't have to do, you know,
follow what Wall Street is
telling me to do next quarter
or something like that.
So I own the brush, I own the canvas,
and the canvas is unlimited,
and that's a pretty nice game,
and I get to do it every
day with people I like.
I don't have to associate with anyone
that causes my stomach to churn, you know?
If I were in politics,
I'd have to smile at a lot of people
that I want to hit, you know?
- So...
- [Interviewer] You
just don't talk to them.
- So I...
It's really, I've got a good deal.
I'm going to, I'm hanging onto it.
(laughter)
- This is always a great reminder
that you are in control of your own brush.
You are the artist, you
get to paint what you want,
and you are in control of your brush.
Where too often we blame other people.
You might blame your boss
if you have a job that
you're trying to get out of.
You might blame your circumstances.
And as soon as you start
blaming somebody else,
it makes you feel good about yourself,
'cuz it's not your fault anymore, right?
So it's somebody else's fault,
so I can feel better about myself.
But as soon as you give
away that responsibility,
as soon as you give your
brush to somebody else,
then you're never going to grow.
It's hopeless.
You're never going to make
the painting that you want.
And so it always starts with
you picking up your brush
and owning your canvas,
and that may not be a full-time thing.
Like, there's the realities of the world.
You might have a family,
you might have kids,
you might have a spouse,
you might have big debt.
There's lots of reasons, you know,
that are slowing your progress,
but you can still pick
up that brush every day
and paint something, right?
You can spend 30 to 60
minutes every single day
on your business,
and if you did that,
you'll start to see major
growth in your business.
What ends up happening
is the pressures of life
and everything else that's happening
start beating down on you.
You haven't scheduled in enough time
to focus on your business.
You don't set enough boundaries around it
and say this is sacred
time that I need to focus
on doing the thing that I
say I want to do, right?
If you have this big goal,
you have to start matching
your actions to the goal.
You start out,
you have to start taking
action on the thing
that you say you want to do.
You have to pick up your brush
and every day start painting.
And so for those of you
who haven't gone full-time
or aren't taking enough action,
schedule in the time in
your calendar consistently
so that it's happening.
So, you know, Monday nights at 9:00
and Tuesday nights at 9:00
or whatever the time is that
fits best for your schedule,
make sure it's being put in
there so you have time to paint.
The other side are the entrepreneurs
who start to get bored.
The entrepreneurs who have a business,
who've had some success,
but then they've plateaued,
and they're kind of just
staying here at the same level,
not growing, not getting
anything from it anymore.
And a lot of these
entrepreneurs, this is common.
It's common to get bored of your business.
It's common to then want
to quit your business,
or to look for something
else that you want to do
because this business isn't giving you
the satisfaction and the joy anymore.
And a big reason for that
is because you've dropped the brush.
Like, you've stopped
creating something new.
You let the success that
you've had in the past
be chains that prevent
you from moving forward.
So I was talking to a YouTuber recently
who's going through this,
and he has a successful channel,
he's trying to build it up,
but he's had kind of flat growth,
and he feels like he's
making the same videos
over and over and over again,
and there's no variety
in the content anymore,
and he's not sure what to do about it.
Should he sell his channel?
Should he focus on a different business?
Should he set up other joint ventures?
Should he get into podcasting?
Should he just go and do something else?
And the reason why he's
frustrated and bored
is because he lost the creativity.
He's not doing new things anymore, right?
He dropped his brush.
You have to pick it back up
and just start to paint again
and do something different.
I love the series on my channel.
I love making every new series.
I'm constantly inviting new series in.
If I don't like a series
anymore, I'll drop it,
even if it's really popular,
if I'm not enjoying it,
I'm going to drop it,
because I don't want to come
here and talk to you guys
on a consistent basis on something
I'm not passionate about.
And so we're constantly trying new things,
new series, new ideas.
I'm constantly painting.
My channel is not the same.
Yes, we're making YouTube videos,
but it's not the same as I was a year ago,
and it's not going to
look the same as it will
in another year from now,
and two years, and five
years, and 10 years.
And so the key is to
be constantly evolving
as an entrepreneur,
constantly picking up the brush,
constantly painting new things,
and if you go too long as
a creative entrepreneur
without painting, without expressing,
without putting yourself
into the business,
and you just get stuck
in the day to day grind
of running the operations,
you will get bored, you will crash,
you will want to shut down,
you will want to look at something else,
you will want to sell the business,
you will want to move on.
And so if that's you,
I'd strongly encourage you to look at
how do I consistently find new ways
to pick up the brush and
keep painting in my business.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
how often are you creating
new things for your business?
How often are you
expressing your creativity
into your company?
How consistent is that for you?
Is it daily?
Is it once a week?
Is it once a month?
Is it once a quarter?
I'd love to hear from you.
Leave it down in the comments below.
Also, for people who leave comments
within the first few hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Marcus Campbell.
Marcus, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book "Your One Word"
and making the YouTube
video on it, as well.
I really, really appreciate
the support and the review,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
(hip-hop music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I think you've got to
find what makes you tick.
And I think greatness comes
from when you marry your passion
with your job.
'Cuz I don't really think I have a job.
I just, I love what I do.
And I always say that to kids.
I talk to a lot of kids who
are at university and say,
how do I make a lot of money?
I say, forget the lot of money part.
Find something you're going to be great at
and let the money follow you.
- So what is it about people
who find their passion,
who work hard and never make a dime?
Well, they make a few
dimes, but not enough.
They never get there.
- So, you know, Fanny, it's interesting,
'cuz we have this
conversation all the time.
I live in a very affluent area,
and I have these quarterly dinners,
or I used to, with my neighbors.
So at one point I had 20 guys.
They were all worth hundreds
of millions of dollars.
And we asked that same question.
Can you always be successful,
even if you love what you
do and all the other stuff?
And the reality is, as my dad said,
- If you work hard...
- [Fanny] Right.
- ...you will never be poor in life.
But just because you work hard
doesn't mean you'll be rich.
Sometimes you need to get lucky.
But the reality is that
the harder you work,
it's true, the luckier you get.
- So I don't really remember
the exact day or anything,
but when I was in college
is when I started thinking
about wanting to be an
entrepreneur someday.
So it was, I was not the
kid with the lemonade stand.
You know, I didn't,
I wasn't one of these kids
who was always trying to raise money.
I always wanted to be a
scientist when I was little.
But I'd also always loved computers.
I like, I was lucky, 'cuz
at my age this is unusual,
to have access to a mainframe computer
for my elementary school
when I was in fourth grade,
and quickly learned that there was
a pre-programmed Star Trek
game on that computer,
and then I never did anything
except play Star Trek
with the computer.
So I don't know how formative that was.
It certainly led,
it certainly helped my Star
Trek knowledge considerably.
(laughter)
And, and, but I've always loved computers.
Somewhere in college,
I started watching some of
the people who were, like,
setting up, you know, college
pizza delivery services,
and, you know, kind of
the core entrepreneurs,
and thinking, you know,
this looks like a really fun thing to do.
- I mean, I really,
really enjoy what I do.
I really do.
And I think, you know,
a number of you probably are
interested in consulting,
and I think my only advice,
and I hope that I'm a
few years older than you
so I have the right to give
you a little bit of advice.
But my only advice is pick something
that you will thoroughly enjoy,
whatever that may be.
And I think if you do that, you know,
you will, to answer the
first individual's question,
you'll probably survive in it,
and potentially, maybe
you'll thrive in it.
I mean, I usually don't say this,
but, you know, if I wasn't
paid a lot of money,
I would still do what I do.
I hope, you know,
some of our managing partners
don't see this program,
(laughter)
because my units may get cut.
But I would still do what I do.
You know, I'm surprised on a yearly basis
as to what kind of money I make.
I mean, I just am absolutely surprised.
I would do it for a tenth of what I make.
So, you know, just find
something that you really enjoy,
and I think you'll thrive.